- Thank you for your service.
- Have a seat.
- Oh my gosh.
- I sat down, I was like,
that's not a good host.
I was like, wait. Hello.
- Thank you for your service.
- I know, absolutely.
- Thank you so much.
- And everyone watching also in service.
How are y'all doing?
- Good.
- Yeah.
- Do you usually come to work
together to do something?
- No.
We used to. We used to.
When we both used to work here at NBC.
- Yeah, but it's been a minute.
- It's been a few minutes.
- Yeah. A few minutes.
- A few minutes. I like it.
So you had some health issues,
but you're doing well, right?
- I did. I was late right
about this time last year.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Yeah. I was in the hospital.
I went in for one thing, ended
up having surgery for five.
So it was buy one, get four free.
- Oh my. That's scary.
- No, it was really a
very scary time, Kelly.
- Yeah.
- It was a very scary time.
And Al is one who likes to look
forward, not backward. Okay.
- The Optimist.
- Which is great. Ever the optimist.
But it was a very, very difficult time.
And we are so blessed
to have him in full form
and just great.
- Yeah.
(clapping)
- But I have to say
too, your granddaughter,
she kind of played a role, right?
- Yes. Yeah. I found out
while I was in the hospital
that my oldest girl, Courtney,
was expecting our first grandchild.
- Aw.
And there she is, little Sky.
Oh, you can all go aw. I know.
(clapping)
- So special.
- But more than anything else,
I think just having, knowing
that she was coming along.
That she's coming-
For this last year-
Exactly.
- Because it's been a progression,
but you've just gotten
stronger and stronger.
And so here he is.
- Yeah.
- So now when he drops his underwear
and his stuff on the floor, whatever,
and I wanna get upset with him,
I'm just like, you know-
- They're there at least.
- I could've been dead.
- Oh my god he's gonna use it.
That's gonna be a card.
- Hey, hey-
- This is what you prayed for.
- Hey, it's your fault.
You saved me. Sorry.
- You didn't want me to go anywhere.
So I have to say was it odd to you,
he was singing on Broadway?
That's not normally how we say
and was in Waitress, right?
- I was in Waitress.
How was that first of all?
Did you love it? Are
you gonna do it again?
- Well, I don't know if anybody
really wants to see that,
but it was one of those
things where they said,
my agent called and said, they
want you to be in Waitress.
I said, oh, the hunky Dr. Palmer. No.
They want you to play old Joe.
- Cool, got it.
- It's just kind of a bit of a downer.
- Yeah.
- But it was fun. I had a great time.
- I know, I was gonna
say, was it interesting
to watch him in that way?
'Cause you don't normally.
- It was, I was shocked. I was shocked.
- Yeah.
- Because I had watched-
- Were you more nervous?
- I think she was more scared
because I was gonna make a fool on myself.
- No.
- No I didn't think that.
- You get one life.
- And he wouldn't sing
that much for us at home.
I think he was a little self-conscious.
So when we saw him on
stage the first time-
- Yeah.
- It was the first time I saw him do it.
And I actually teared up. I was like,
Al actually can sing a little bit.
- Oh, that's so cool.
- Yeah.
- So it was really a lot of fun.
- And again, it was a
really nice title of a song.
Take it from an old man.
- Yeah.
- I know you were like doubting the role,
but I actually love that.
I think old Joe would
be fun. That'd be cool.
So wait, I wanna talk
about your new documentary.
- It's called, it's called Gaining Ground,
the Fight for Black Land.
It's this incredible problem
in this country where
in 1920 there was about 20 million acres
of farmland owned by black farmers.
And we're down to less than 2 million now.
And through different
heirs, property rights,
where if one person
decides they wanna sell,
everybody has to sell,
the lack of proper wills
and things like that.
So we look at this through the lens of
how do we reverse this?
And we were partnered with
John Deere, the tractor folks.
- Yeah. Oh, I know who they are.
- Yeah.
And interestingly, John
Deere was an abolitionist,
you know, back in the day.
- Yeah.
I don't know the backstory on John Deere.
That's interesting.
- Yeah.
Yeah. So, they really
tried to put in place
a legacy that will help going forward,
farmers, you know, get their land.
The interesting fact is the
fastest growing demographic
for new farmers, is people
of color and women, so.
- I would be one of those
people 'cause I'm doing that
on my ranch. Yeah.
- There you go.
- And it's a hard life.
- Yep.
- So, but it's very fascinating.
And I think everybody wants
to get back to non GMO
and really healthy stuff.
'Cause we all know that that's medicine.
- Farm to table.
- Yeah.
- We're what we eat literally.
- Yeah. Don't I know it.
So two things.
You just released a book recently.
- Yes.
- What is the title?
- I love this book. It's
called Lessons Learned
and Cherished, the Teacher
Who Changed My Life.
And it's a collection of essays from
a lot of notable people.
Some of them maybe you
don't know, a lot you do.
Who talk about that
teacher who just changed
something for them.
- I love that.
- And it's a salute to teachers.
- I'm gonna love that.
- I have a copy for you.
- You left a copy for me. I know.
I'm very excited.
- I'm excited for you.
- But also congratulations,
because you were named 2020 Anchor.
- Thank you. Thank you.
- Yes, this is huge.
- With David Muir.
- Yeah.
- I'm so excited to step in. Thank you.
- You're clapping, but
you're kind of competitors.
- Not really. She gets
real news and I just-
- Oh my god do not, do not.
- Oh my gosh.
But I'm just really thrilled
because Barbara Walters,
of course started this program.
- Yeah.
- Along with Hugh Downs.
And to be there in this
space that Barbara occupied
all those years after
having worked with her
for so many years.
- I was gonna say she was a mentor, right?
- She was absolutely a mentor.
- Yeah.
- I watched and followed Barbara.
I mean, she was iconic.
- Yeah.
- I grew up watching her.
- So it's a great responsibility
and I'm just honored and humbled.
Oh, you're beaming about it.
Yeah. Your eyes are smiling.
That's wonderful. I love that.
Do you think it's gotten
better for women in news?
- Oh, absolutely.
- There always can be progress.
- Of course. We see women in
so many different roles, right?
But it's more important to
see women behind the scenes.
And we are starting to see,
but we need more women behind the scenes.
- Yeah.
But the industry has changed tremendously.
I mean, to see so many
heads of news divisions
and so forth, it's really great to see.
- And especially when
it's a producing team
and they're producing something.
Like if it's a woman
producing something about
a woman, it's like, that makes sense.
- Yeah.
- Yeah those are things that make sense.
So how's Today going?
- Everything's going great.
- I just there recently.
- I know, I know.
In fact, the head of the Today brand,
Libby Least our Uber producer.
- You know, we have a great time.
It's just a really good family.
- You have a great crew.
- Hoda, Carson, Craig, Chanel.
Chanel Jones ran the
New York City marathon.
- Oh my gosh.
- For the first time. Did a fantastic job.
- That was who I was
waving at from my house
because I was like, never me.
- Al ran it. Al ran it years ago.
- You did?
- I did. I did.
- There's too many things
that can go wrong with chafing
and people I hear have
to go to the bathroom
and I'm like, and they just go.
- I had chafed nipples.
- Oh.
I'm just not about that life.
But I'm so proud of people that do it.
- I'll give you a sense
of how fast I ran it.
Our daughter Lela said at
the end, she said, daddy,
what did the snail say on top of the turf?
- Oh no.
- I don't know. Wee.
- But you're like, well,
what did the snail say
when he finished something?
- That's right.
- You have covered,
both of you have covered
so many military stories.
Is there one that sticks
out to you, Deborah?
- I remember prior to
the nine eleven attack,
we had another attack on US
soil the very, very first time.
And I did a story up in
Massachusetts about a young woman
who was getting ready to go to college,
who decided she wanted to
go and serve her country.
She was called to action into duty.
And there were a number of
people who were deciding,
I want to serve my country.
- Yeah.
- And I remember just
being so in awe of that,
that whole spirit of wanting to serve.
- Selflessness.
So that was actually one
that I will never forget.
I was really very impressed by that woman.
- Yeah. Called to a higher purpose.
That's really, really
beautiful. What about you?
- You know, I had read about this story,
it was the battalion,
the six triple eight.
It was the only battalion
of all women of color
who were sent overseas-
(applause)
they were the six triple
eight coastal battalion.
There was a backlog of about
18 months mail to and from,
from the front lines that could not get.
And they were led by the
first black female colonel.
They went over first to England,
then behind the enemy lines in France.
And within six months had the mail service
running to and from.
And I had the pleasure
and honor of interviewing
Ms. Lena King, who is still
alive. She's 101 years old.
- Dang.
- Yes.
(applause)
There were 855 of these women,
only six are still alive.
And I got to meet one other,
but also got to interview Ms. King.
She's still sharp as a tack.
And so one of the things she said was,
we wanted to show that
we loved our country,
even though our country
didn't always love us back.
- Yeah. Well that's real love. Yeah.
I love what the Today Show did too.
Y'all actually lobbied for
these women to be recognized.
- That's right.
They got their Congressional
medal of honor.
Many of them posthumously.
(applause)
It really meant, it meant
a lot. It meant a lot.
- And it does matter.
Getting those letters matter.
That's really important.
- Before emails.
- Yeah, absolutely. That's
what I'm saying, yeah.
This is, it's even more important.
Well, everybody, you can
see Al on the Today Show
every morning on NBC if you
didn't already know that.
And also in the third hour of today.
And also watch Deborah Friday
evenings on 2020 on ABC.